[Music]
well i know he's a lunatic i don't have
to think that he's a lunatic just look
at it objectively
he made our country unfortunately poorer
weaker and sicker
they do send out a bit of mixed messages
or they send out
you know mixed instructions on what we
can and can't do
and it keeps i feel like it keeps
changing young women
people in their teens in their 20s are
leading the charge and helping make the
change
and we need to get out of the way allow
them to lead
we're here to help we're here to give
people courage and hope
really we're here to sort of um
put a smile on people's faces
donald trump is a lunatic who's made
america poorer weaker and sicker the
blunt assessment from the former white
house communications director anthony
scaramucci
he was sacked by the president after
only 11 days in the white house
after comments he made about ex-trump
adviser steve bannon
were reported in the new yorker magazine
perhaps not surprisingly mr scaramucci
is now backing
joe biden in the u.s election we have to
start with your relationship with the
president
of course you only lasted 11 days as the
white house communications director back
in 2017 what happened
well i mean i did work from for a year
prior to that and i was on the executive
transition team but
but i think you guys know what happened
it was a well-documented mistake i uh
i trusted a reporter who was a you know
family friend the
his dad had gone back with my dad uh in
the construction community on long
island
for 50 years and i said a off-color
remark
to him which he recorded unfortunately
and he ran to cnn and
i said to him hey if you do that you're
going to get me fired
and of course he did that and i got
fired so it was my fault
i don't blame anybody for that i was
right about steve bannon by the way but
i shouldn't have said it the way i said
it but that's life how should you have
said it do you think
well i think uh uh you know the truth be
told
uh when you did a clinical assessment an
objective assessment about steve bannon
he was a megalomaniacal egocentric
uh white nationalist and so a very
dangerous guy to have in the white house
and so
for me uh i think my singular greatest
accomplishment thus far
in american history was helping to get
him out of that white house
what do you say to those who say you're
just being bitter because you were fired
by the president
well i mean they're entitled to that
opinion but just look at the record i
was with the president i got fired
for two years you can find tons of video
of me
advocating for the president and
advocating his policies
but once he started putting separating
women from their children at the border
and putting the children in cages
disavowing our intelligence community
using racial slurs on his twitter
account it became impossible
it has very very little to do with me
being fired
and again for two years after my firing
i tried to stay loyal to him and his
agenda
but you can't stay loyalty in life is
symmetrical it's not asymmetrical
you can't stay loyal to lunacy and so uh
we'll be out there working to see him
uh go back to mar-a-lago and hopefully
we can
calm things down he made our country
unfortunately poorer weaker and sicker
and we need to heal that now do you
think he's a lunatic
well i know he's a lunatic i don't have
to think that he's a lunatic just look
at it objectively
uh yeah of course he's a lunatic i mean
come on here's the problem what we do in
our society because he's in that august
office you know he's the successor of
eisenhower and roosevelt
and abraham lincoln we have a tendency
to attach
normalcy to somebody that is very
abnormal and i i understand that
i did that in the beginning i tried to
do that even after i got fired but
no you could look at this objectively
and say that the guy is a full-blown
lunatic
how do you think the president might
react if he loses on the third
of november will he take it on the chin
i think he will i think ultimately what
you find
with bullies and cowards like this you
know he's a keyboard warrior coward
i think he's going to get humiliated at
the polls and i think he'll he'll leave
if it's a super tight race he may fake a
head fake of that he's not going to do
that but he obviously
will do that he's called you it got
personal he's called you a nervous
neurotic wreck do you regret working for
him
the one that was really hurtful was he
called me an unstable nut job so i think
that that was the one that really got to
me gaming
was very upset about that that comment i
mean listen i mean that's his projection
anything that he's saying about a guy
like me or a guy like general mattis or
a guy like rex tillerson
is a projection frankly of how he feels
about himself and so
i don't mind when he calls me those
things i i wear those as a
badge of honor but if you notice i don't
really call him
those things i just look at it very
objectively and say that this is not a
person that
is fit to be the president of the united
states
and so let's move on and we should be
brave enough
to fear no man or woman for that matter
and speak our conscious about what's
going on in our society
[Music]
this hasn't gone away this is a virus
we're going to have to live with
the number of people who can gather in
pubs and parks
and perhaps most significantly in homes
will be reduced from 30
down to six young people don't just
spread the virus to each other they
spread the virus to their parents and
their grandparents
so are we vilifying the younger members
of our society and blaming them for the
progression
of the pandemic and is that fair i do
feel that
the government has given the green light
for a lot of things to happen so they
eat out to help out over 100 meals
have been served and we all have
responsibility but ostracizing
one single generation um as young people
are being ostracized by and picked upon
by
matt hancock and it just singles them
out and it's so unfair
to do so i think we'll have a level of
responsibility and most people that
often shift the power of blame um are
the ones that don't have clean hands
themselves so matt hancock
really needs to pick his words a bit
more wisely and especially that one of
them
don't kill your gran how confident and
aware have you been about what you can
and can't do what the guidelines are
what the the law is and
when you speak to your friends how aware
are they
of the restrictions one point they're
saying you know they're encouraging us
to go to work they're encouraging us
to socialize socialize with friends to
take part in the
um help out to eat health scheme um
and then it comes to times like these
and now they're telling us
you know that we are the cause we're the
cause to um
the rise in the chronic coronavirus
cases so
um when they're telling us um to do
these things and they're telling us to
socialize and speaking with friends of
mine and and them saying that they're
pretty confused themselves
um i think sometimes they do send out a
bit of mixed
messages or they send out you know mixed
instructions on what we can and can't do
and it keeps i feel like it keeps
changing it keeps changing as the time
goes on
we are being brushed under into one
category um obviously
there is a awful lot of young people
across the whole of the uk
um and legal waves i think we have all
been blamed for stuff like this
and like i said i i mean i don't have
many friends i don't have a huge social
bubble
um i i kind of go out by myself on the
night i've got a few select friends
so again i i've never really like been
to a party so again it's like my style
of
lifestyle is completely different to
what we're being branded as
the aim is to keep schools and
universities open and running to keep
people in education and that is why
measures like this restricting social
gatherings
have to happen is that a fair price to
pay
in all honesty yes i do think it's a
fair price to pay because
um you know me personally i want to stay
at university i want to continue with my
course
and i'm pretty sure a lot of students
want to continue with their education as
well
so reducing reducing the um social
gathering size
to six um i think is fair because
you know precautions do need to be put
into place um you need to have
boundaries you need to have
something you know you can't just let
things run free because at the end of
the day um
coronavirus still is a serious thing and
people do need to still take it
seriously because
people have sadly passed away from this
and alex you've already paid a price as
a result
of coronavirus just tell us what
happened to you
so i was sadly made redundant at the end
of august
um which isn't very good um obviously
you've got universal credit which i can
apply for
but again we're in this small group of
young people
and i'm entitled 254 pounds a month
which to be honest only just covers me
carb insurance
during the pandemic jobs in retail and
in the service industry
usually filled by students on their
summer holidays have been drastically
cut
new figures obtained exclusively by sky
news suggest some
young people are now making the
difficult decision to consider
sex work in a financial emergency that's
led to
empowerment for some but many others
have put themselves
at risk i began my sex work journey in
2014 going on sugar daddy dates for
money
i was then later forced into full
service sex work
by someone i loved i felt empowered when
i had a choice
but when i had no choice out of
financial desperation and the fact i was
told i didn't have a choice
i began to lose the ability to feel
human by the end of it
jessica was raped multiple times she has
post-traumatic stress disorder
partly a result of enforced sex work she
says
she was desperate for money i went to
several
mental health institutions for support
and they turned me away because i was a
sex worker even though i begged them to
help me stop
i had no family to help me
i was just completely alone with it and
struggling
so much i remember there was one time
where
there was a glass of water in front of
me and i couldn't get up to get the
water
and like i was getting turned away by
the end of it because
i was just i couldn't i couldn't do it i
wasn't up to the job
and the last time i did sex work ever
i cried in the middle of it and he let
me keep the money and go home
and you worried other people will feel
the same as you did i don't ever want
anyone to feel like i did
i know i don't i i would be there for
anybody that came to me to stop
them feeling like i did and that's why
she set up what is currently the
country's
only student sex worker support group
based in manchester
and helping people throughout the
pandemic for me
it's not just about helping the whole
community it's about the individual
i think if you can make a difference in
one individual's life
and you've made all the difference in
the world there's been an overall
increase in sex work altogether
people have been let girlfriend in their
jobs temporarily and permanently
and universal credit doesn't pay enough
for people to live on
which is a it's a positive thing because
in the sector
sex work is becoming more and more
accepted as a job but it
presents its risks
wayne wilson is better known to millions
of viewers as dwight in the u.s version
of the office
now he's fronting an online show the
idiot's guide to climate change
interviewing some of the biggest names
in environmental activism such as greta
timmberg
he spoke to our special programme on
climate change
in the absence of any kind of global
leadership or leadership from central
governments
how important is it do you think for
individuals to take action
well this is this is my favorite topic
of all and this is one of the most
important topics there is
this is the trouble with climate change
and it sucks
sorry there's no better word for it is
that i as an individual can't
do very much and that is incredibly
frustrating
so you have a lot of people thinking
well i'm just one person
i can eat beef you know i can have lots
of food waste i can drive a
you know an old truck that creates a lot
of diesel exhaust
what difference do i make i'm just this
is seven billion people on the planet
and giant corporations and giant
governments
what difference do i make but you
you make a huge difference we make a
huge difference we all make a huge
difference because yes one person
doesn't
uh tip the scales but you know a
thousand
maybe ten thousand does then if a
hundred thousand people are all doing
the same thing
if a million people quit eating beef if
ten million people
start to reduce their their carbon
footprint if a hundred million people
start changing their ways
start commuting with bicycles instead of
with cars
all of a sudden we can see an impact
we've been talking a lot in the uk about
the need for a green
recovery after the pandemic is that sort
of debate being had in the united states
at the moment
you know it's been called a green new
deal but we just
the point is is that after this
pandemic we can't go back to normal we
really
we really cannot afford to go back to
normal this
affords us an opportunity for a giant
reset
you know a giant reboot uh of
our priorities uh moving forward what
sort of areas do you think
you're thinking of most within your life
and within your family circle about
how you can make an impact we are going
to need to make personal
sacrifices uh we we love in the western
world to have a life of total
convenience where we can
hit a button on amazon and anything we
want shows up at our doorstep a day or
two later
but we're going to have to shift things
to have a longer-term
view we've got to plant trees
support environmental organizations and
most importantly
we have to vote for science vote for
people that are behind the science
do you feel optimistic it's very easy to
get pessimistic when you look
at the data and we look at some of the
things that happen
but there is a movement among young
people and that's where i feel my
greatest optimism
is what we just explored in the idiot's
guide to climate change
is that this leadership like greta
tunberg who i got to interview
and katie eider and so many other people
that
young women people in their teens in
their 20s are leading the charge and
helping make the change
and we need to get out of the way allow
them to lead
and that's really inspiring the amount
of young people
that are behind the kind of drastic
change that humanity is going to need to
make
to fix this thing
[Music]
let's talk about the tennis style novak
djokovic who's apologized for hitting a
line judge with the ball at the u.s open
and says he's been left sad and empty
after being disqualified from it
while the world number one had just had
a serve broken on fourth round match
took a ball out of his pocket hid it
behind him in anger and struck
this woman in her throat there is there
something in the gladiatorial nature of
tennis at this top level
and we think back to mcenroe i suppose
jimmy connors as well
uh temper tantrums were half of the
course and arguably
necessary for stoking them lots of
athletes will have those temper tantrums
one of the
um the biggest issues in sport is being
able to
control and manage our emotions when
something really really matters to us
so the higher you get in sport the more
it matters to you
the more you're going to have to
struggle to control those emotions but
obviously the more important it becomes
how do athletes tread that line how do
they balance the emotions because you
want them to
to have some strength of feeling don't
you when they go into a game
so how what are the tricks for balancing
you need to feel activated you need to
feel
pumped up you need to feel that
adrenaline and that cortisol
rushing around your body getting you
ready to play
but where you want that is making you
feel like it's a great challenge ahead
of you that it's really exciting that
you get to play
not like a threat and when it really
matters to you
and when you start to lose it suddenly
seems like a threat
and at that point the wrong bit of our
brain switches on and starts causing all
sorts of trouble
as we saw in this case yeah getting
pumped up that's just like before we
come on for the show jane isn't it
just some degree feeling speak for
yourself
i suppose joseph partly this is a
functional it may be a function of where
the trajectory of your career happens to
be i mean if it's all the upward curve
then fine if you're managing decline and
the joint's getting creakier
i'm not suggesting that's djokovic's
problem you're still in pretty fine
fettle it appears
then that that may be something you you
know you get angry about
and we have no idea what's going on in
an athlete's head
when they're competing they may have all
sorts of fears and worries
and small niggles that might be going on
that are making them
much more hyper alert to that threat
making them
really worried and it means instead of
being able to take something in their
stride
they will react the wrong way very
quickly we talk about the
the link between um mental instability
and and genius in lots of in lots of
different
fields you know especially artists do
you think there's an
there's an element of that in sport that
you almost have to be a little bit
uh crazy to get to the top of your game
because you have to have such
absolute single-minded determination and
block out everything else
there are many many athletes who have
very high levels of perfectionism
and that can do wonderfully for making
them set really high goals for work
incredibly hard to achieve what they
need to do
but there's a real downside of
perfectionism in that it's impossible to
be perfect
and so there is always going to be that
real edge
of not quite being able to achieve what
you want to achieve
and feeling like a failure as a result
of that
i think that's where a lot of athletes
will struggle
[Music]
now there's been lots of very heavy
serious news about today
lighten things up just a little bit
before you give you a little bit of a
break
and take you back in time a little bit
now i have to tell you
the caribbean queen herself jillian when
she's here
we sing this quite a lot in the
commercial breaks
that's the stuff you don't get to hear
thankfully it is of course by the music
legend billy ocean
how did a lad from romford end up being
becoming a global superstar how did it
happen
oh it's the gift listen let's run for
it's like eastern
white chapel brooklyn that's where
that's where i'm from basically
and how did it happen i don't know how
does this happen to other people
just pursuing what you think you're best
at i was never
very academic so i pursued the thing
that they enjoy
i pursued a thing that that um
that i was interested in interested in
which is music
and you know by the grace of god it's
paid off for me
and it's um i think i'm more surprised
than anyone else you know because
after the success of my first record in
1976 which was lovely years without you
i never thought i'd have any more hit
records but you know
i proved myself wrong i i ended up
having uh
seven top tens in america and four
number ones you know and
different things all over the world i
was dreaming about having
success in america and i did get it and
when you look back billy
on on your on your long uh and very
successful
career what are you most proud of i
think i'm
more proud of my longevity the fact that
i've been able to sustain that success
um and be brave enough and as i get
older
i get more and more confidence to to to
to
you know to do different sort of music
to do write different sort of songs
to you know to write songs that that has
you know social like so the social
comments in it
rise tone that that sort of awakens
people consciousness
etc etc i mean that's what we're here
for we're not just here
you know people like myself that's in
the public eye that has
that can influence people in in in in
different
uh areas of their life we're here to
sort of
we're here to help we're here to give
people courage and hope
really we're here to sort of
put a smile on people's faces